مرحبا
فتحه دائريه كان يسموها الغوزن
[موسيقى]
عادات وتقاليد والطقوس الرمضانيه الموصل
المدينه غنيه بالتراث مدينه مدينه لها كان
طقوس خاصه في كل المناسبات
الحرب دمرت كل شيء دمرت الذاكره دمرت
المراقبه دمرت المناره مشهوره بجامعه
وكنائيسه
المحبه
[موسيقى]
اليوم نحن في مؤسسه بيتنا ونحن كشباب
مجموعه من الشباب نحاول ان نعيد كل التراث
المادي والغير مادي لمدينه الموصل فتره
الحرب حتى قبل الحرب فتره قبل 2014 الظروف
الامنيه
قتلت هذه العادات والتقاليد والطقوس
الرمضانيه الموصل المدينه غنيه بالتراث
مدينه
لها كانت طقوس خاصه في كل المناسبات
[تصفيق]
رمضان هناك العديد من المناسبات والعديد
من الطقوس في الماكل في المشرق في الملبس
في المناسبات ليله القدر لها طعم خاص ليله
رمضان لها طعم خاص
[موسيقى]
الحرب دمرت كل شيء دمرت الذاكره دمرت
المرافق دمرت المناره لم لم تبقي شيء في
مدينه الموصل ممكن ان نجيل جديد ويحاول ان
يرى تراث اجداده وما صنعوه لهذا احنا كان
على واجبنا ان نحفز وننشط هذه الذاكره
الجيل الجديد ونحاول ان نلصقهم مره ثانيه
بماضيهم
في مؤسسه بيتنا حرصنا ان يكون
نشاطات شهر رمضان تليق وتناسب هذه الايام
بداناها في الاستفراش شهر رمضان كان من
قبل الاطفال
والتجوال في الجامعه النور الكبيره
ومنارتها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كذلك راح نشاهد اليوم المسحراتي الذي هو
ايضا الطقوس الطقس من طقوس رمضان
[موسيقى]
اخترنا في هذا اليوم ان نقدم شخصيه موصليه
عريقه
سيقدم للناس الحكواتي ويعيد هذا الطقس او
هذه العاليه المهمه في رمضان مع الاجواء
الجديده
فقررت اليوم انا حكيت لكم بعض ذكريات
الموصل خلى الصينيه خله حجيه خير
فكره القصه اخونا كانت في وقتها هو اول
النقل الاخبار ونقل القصص والماثر والدرجه
الثانيه هي الموعظه تحفيز الناس على الخير
والشراكه والجيره ليش ماسك بدل ما تضي
ع في الموصل ينشط ويشتهر فيها المداح
انفجار رمضان وتشوف موجودين في الحارات او
العوجات الازقه احنا نسميها القديمه
يمدحون وينشدون
يعني يباركون للناس هذا الشهر
[موسيقى]
كذلك الجانب الاخر وهو
الفوانيس والتعليق والزنا الرمضانيه كل
هذه الطقوس وكل هذه الاجواء نحاول فيها ان
نشط الذاكره ان نحفز الناس على المجيء الى
هذه المساحه او المنطقه القديمه بشكل عام
نجحنا لي في تسليط الضوء على هذه النشاطات
وجلب الناس ان كانت السياحه الداخليه او
الخارجيه من المحافظات ومؤخرا الخليجيين
والسياحه الاجانب الذين ايضا بدو يحتاجون
الموصل مع زياره البابا وصولهم الى هنا
انا على اعتقاد انتصار خاصه بعد ما كانت
هذه المدينه مدمره
شهباء من سلطنه عمان في زياره الى الموصل
القديمه
[موسيقى]